en este vídeo vamos a multiplicar 36 por
27 estamos multiplicando un número de
dos dígitos por otro número de dos
dígitos y la manera en que lo vamos a
hacer es multiplicando 36 por 7 y traten
de pensar cuánto es esto y luego vamos a
multiplicar 36 por 20 también traten de
pensar cuánto nos da esto y finalmente
vamos a sumar esos resultados y lo
primero que quiero hacer es mostrarles
el proceso de multiplicar estos dos
números y luego lo vamos a volver a
hacer tratando de pensar en lo que cada
uno de esos números representa así que
empecemos con el proceso primero
multiplica 36 por 7 y empiezo por las
unidades entonces 7 por 6 642 escribo el
2 aquí abajo y el 4 que representa 40 lo
pongo en el lugar de las decenas 7 por 3
es 21 más 4 que llevamos es igual a 25
así que voy a escribir el 25 completo
aquí abajo no hay más números arriba en
la posición de las antenas donde podamos
llevar este 2 por eso
vivimos completo aquí abajo ahora para
continuar voy a quitar este número para
que no haya confusión y ya descubrimos
cuánto es 36 por 7 es igual a 252 ahora
vamos a enfocarnos en el resultado de 36
por 20 queremos saber cuánto es 36 por
20 y lo que vamos a hacer es escribir un
cero aquí porque ahora vamos a
multiplicar 36 por algo que está en el
lugar de las decenas este no es
simplemente 2 es 20 entonces es
importante que pensemos en la posición
de los dígitos y vamos a multiplicar
todos por 6 que es igual a 12 y
escribimos el 2 aquí y llevamos 12 por 3
es igual a 6 más uno es igual a 7 y
ahora descubrimos que 36 por 20 es igual
a 720 y pensemos qué hubiera pasado si
no ponemos este cero aquí habríamos
obtenido 72 de multiplicar 36 por 2
pero este 2 no es realmente 2 es 20 así
que 36 por 20
a 720 y ahora podemos sumar estos
números porque 36 por 27 es lo mismo que
36 por 7 más 36 por 20 entonces vamos a
sumar 2 + 0 es igual a 25 más dos es
igual a 72 + 7 es 9 y el resultado es
972 ahora vamos a hacer otra vez esta
multiplicación pero de otra manera esta
vez vamos a hablar de lo que estos
dígitos representan en este primer
ejercicio revisamos el proceso para
resolver la multiplicación ahora vamos a
pensar en lo que los dígitos realmente
representan bueno vamos a multiplicar 36
por 7 entonces 7 por 6 o 7 veces 6 es
igual a 42 escribo aquí el 2 en el lugar
de las unidades y el 40 lo escribe en el
lugar de las decenas este 4 representa
47 por 30 es igual a 210 más 40 es igual
a 250 y ya teníamos este 2 aquí en las
unidades así que
el resultado es 252 36 por 7 es 252
ahora quito este número y multiplico 20
por 6 que nos da 120 así que escribo el
20 en el lugar de las decenas y llevamos
100 hoy llevamos 1 que representa 100 y
ahora 20 por 30 es igual a 600 más 100
que llevamos nos da 700 vemos que al
multiplicar 36 por 20 nos da como
resultado 720 el 7 está en el lugar de
las centenas y el 2 en el lugar de las
decenas y luego podemos sumar igual que
lo hicimos la última vez
y obtenemos 972